Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies a lot of
people in the audience uh either hold
them or interested in them learning
about them you've mentioned a couple of
times that many of your clients uh or
are at least now becoming interested
have become interested what are you
seeing there is there anything
specifically at the kind of intersection
of crypto and whether it's estate
planning tax planning anything like that
well yeah I I've seen a lot of elements
in the last particularly two or three
years you know I know crypto's been
around longer than that but the people
that had crypto five and ten years ago
they weren't necessarily wealthy and the
banks didn't really care about them now
all of a sudden you know you have this
whole new
um class of people that are you know
multi-millionaires and even billionaires
and uh I think a lot of the traditional
financial institutions Banks trust
companies insurance companies they're
they're all starting to take notice so
you have some of the early movers in the
space
um you know Dell tech in in the Bahamas
you have Bank Frick in in Liechtenstein
that really led the way in what they
called crossover Finance
um the these were some of the banks that
were really out there now you know even
some of the I you read almost every day
in the news about you know the
traditional the Merrell lynches or the
bank Americas and and and they're trying
to figure out ways to cater to uh the
crypto Community uh We've we've seen uh
trust companies come up with new ways to
be able to properly hold uh crypto that
that's something they never had to do
they you know they work with companies
like fire blocks and you know other
companies that can provide the the kind
of security that that clients want you
know I mean somebody's not going to walk
in off the street and say you know
here's uh here's the flash drive with uh
you know two thousand three thousand
four thousand Bitcoin and you know I'm
just gonna Fork it over to wherever you
know is nice to me they want proof that
the that the um security you know is at
the very highest level and and I think
that as we go forward the next three
four five years as Bitcoin makes another
you know Bull Run and becomes a lot more
valuable again uh you know you'll have
the financial institutions that figure
out how to keep up and and cater and
serve uh the crypto community and and
those who don't and the ones who don't
you know I think a lot of them will will
go out of business or or or or become
sort of the the second tier you know
probably local Community Banks maybe
won't uh but the big banks that want to
cater to wealthy people they're they're
basically being forced to learn quickly
hire people from those sectors to come
in and help them organize their Affairs
and as you said there's there's sort of
two groups you've got wealthy people
from some other industry they made their
money in real estate or you know their
their business or whatever and now they
want to sort of dabble in the in the
crypto space they're sort of the late
comers they've come along in the last
one or two or three years but then the
other group are the people that were the
the early adopters you know they were
they were getting you know Bitcoin when
it was under ten dollars you know
ethereum it you know pennies and and
those people are you know that's a very
very interesting crowd you know a lot of
them never thought that they were
wealthy they still don't think of
themselves as wealthy
um you know and they are just slowly
coming out of the woodwork and we we
talk to those folks every day and that's
what they want to know they want to know
okay if I engage in traditional asset
protection estate planning you know can
the structures keep up the legal
structures first and foremost but then
the the financial institutions you know
how can I be certain how can I sleep at
night knowing that you know my my
bitcoin's safe and and a lot of them
come from the crowd where you know it's
it's sitting on a flash drive somewhere
and they're the only ones that know
about it but we've all read about the
stories of you know the guy who threw
away his computer in New York and he had
a hundred million dollars of a Bitcoin
on it so so that's a bit of a wake-up
call as well and you know they they do
want traditional asset protection estate
planning you know if they get hit by a
bus tomorrow and die they want to make
sure that their kids and you know their
family can and Charities whomever can
access their their wealth so it's a
balancing act we have to
um you know convince folks that the the
right kind of systems and structures are
in place it is new these you know like I
said if I if I I've been doing this 32
years but in the crypto space only
probably less than five so all of the
banks and Trust companies they're all
scurrying around some faster than others
to to really put the the best
system structures protocols in place to
serve the crypto community and and you
know I think crypto sitting right now
about two two trillion all of the crypto
industry but you know as as Bitcoin as
the leader and ethereum takes off again
you know that number is only going to
increase so I think more and more
financial institutions will be wanting
to cater to to that clientele and uh
it's really it's really pretty exciting
I mean you know I'm sort of in the
Twilight of My Career but you know it's
it's the old dogs learning new tricks
and try to adapt things that I've been
working with you know my whole career to
the the crypto community and it's it's
been you know very exciting